- Good evening everyone and
thank you for joining us.
Whether you're here in person
or joining us virtually,
we're excited to have you.
My name is Andrei Okhotnikov
and I lead product management
for AWS Marketplace
deployments experience,
which includes the fast growing category
of AI agents and tools.
And I have two amazing
co-presenters with me today.
Salman Tahir and he is
the global AI partner lead
who's working closely
with many of the partners
who are building the next
generation of AI agents and tools.
And we have a special
guest today, Mira Rajaram
head of AI core services
at Workday Planning,
who's bringing the practitioner experience
of building and
operationalizing AI agents.
We're excited to take you
through today's session,
build agentic workflows on AWS
with third party agents and tools.
Before we dive in, let's
do a little warmup.
Please raise your hands if
you have built an AI agent.
Nice.
Please keep them up.
I see a few.
Keep them up, keep them up.
Keep them up if you have more than
five AI agents running in
production in your organization.
Nice.
I see a few hands, more than 10?
Okay, less hands but still we got a few.
Cool.
So the goal of today's
session is to show you
how AWS
and the partner ecosystem
give you a strong foundation
for building agentic solutions.
By the end of the session,
we want to make sure you
get the strong understanding
of all the foundation
and actually get ready to put
your hands on the keyboard
and get started building
the agentic workflows.
So here's the plan for
the next 60 minutes.
We'll start with the basics,
the overview of AWS agentic stack,
which includes the core services,
some of the architecture principles,
and the recommendations
which we have collected
from our customers who are building
agent applications right now.
After that I'll give a quick
overview of AWS Marketplace
and how AI agents
and tools from third party
vendors can help you building
agentic applications
and specifically how you can use them
in the new set of agentic services
on AWS in AgentCore runtime
and AgentCore gateway.
After that I'll pass
Mira to walk us through
Workday's example of
building the planning agents.
So you'll hear some inside
stories of what's going well,
what's not going well of
building and operationalizing AI.
Next Salman will walk us
through a hands-on experience
of building an agentic workflow
using third party tools.
So you'll see how to get started from zero
to a ready to go agent and
we'll wrap up this presentation
with the demo of a prebuilt agent
which you can get from Marketplace
and which you can deploy in a few minutes.
So let's get started.
- Fantastic, thank you so much Andrei.
Hi everyone.
So agents, when we talk
about agents, it's important
to acknowledge their agency,
they need to be able to act
and with AI there are two additional
attributes that are important.
They need to be able
to take on instructions
and form a goal and an objective
that they would be able to achieve.
And then the second one is that
we should be able to reason
and plan in order to be
able to take advantage
of those tools that are available.
So agency is super important
and with AI it's able to
capture a high level goal
and it's able to reason
and plan in order to invoke
the right tools in order
to serve the outcome to the user.
And today we'll see that, you
know, not only we'll see it,
we'll hear about these
experiences that we've had with
AgentCore and building agents
and Mira's gonna be
talking about it later on.
So it's very much an evolution.
We've had RPA bots in the past
where for static workflows
we've been able to bring automation
over time That's evolved
into cognitive automation,
enhanced workflows with ML
capabilities and AI capabilities
and generative AI assistance came about
where we were forming these prompts
and queries, sending them
over to a foundation model,
getting a response back.
But now with agents as I highlighted,
they can really do a reasoning, planning
and they can form that collaboration
where they can take on an
objective more than just a task,
fulfill that objective and
return a response to us.
And over time we're gonna
see fully autonomous systems.
So there's a maturity curve
shifting from low agency
to higher agency bot agents
and the role of a human from, you know,
actually doing the work in the past
is shifting over to more of an oversight.
Now in AWS there are three areas
that we're deeply focused on.
First one, choice,
bringing the latest market
leading capabilities
to our customers and partners
so they can freely innovate,
innovate fast, realize ROI
and value quickly is important
and then move in, move along
with the latest capabilities
that come within the market landscape.
Second one, trust.
AI has been probabilistic
it will likely remain probabilistic.
So it's important to be
able to control, govern,
establish guardrails and compliance
for using these agents production.
And the third one is around scale,
because whilst the key
component of these LLMs
and so the tools are fundamental,
the end-to-end solution
compromise of multiple components
and having enterprise grade capabilities
that would allow you to quickly innovate,
move those into production
and then scale that
production as your demand
and adoption grows is super important.
And that's what we bring from AWS.
I'm gonna briefly touch
upon each one of these
firstly around choice.
So with choice, the
ability to buy or build
or partner depending on the use case,
depending on your strategy,
is extremely important.
So at the top you see some of
our AWS native capabilities
with quick suite and
third party capabilities
that Andra is gonna be talking
about from Marketplace.
In the second layer you have
Amazon Bedrock AgentCore
as well as Strands agents as a framework
where you can build any custom agentic
solution of your choice.
And this is where you know if
your use case in particular
does not fit one of those
out of the box models,
we see that the ability to be able
to build your custom agent is important.
Lastly, bringing partners
who have the expertise
and experience within AWS
with the AWS Generative
AI Innovation Center,
but also our partners
professional services is important
and that's an area where you can partner
in order to build those solutions.
Take advantage of the lessons learned
and the best practices
that has been accumulated over many runs
and many build scenarios.
And in this context, we're
providing the capability
that would be able to work with any models
and any frameworks and
that's a flexibility
and the choice that
would speak to our value.
Now in terms of trust,
security, governance, audit,
I wanna highlight three points here.
The first one around transparency
is extremely important
to acknowledge what are the
models that are available,
how services are developed,
what are the intended use cases?
In fact, we started this
with our AI services
where we had AI service cards
and we've now extended those
into our agentic AI capabilities
where we talk about how
they've been trained,
what type of data it's been used,
what are the intended applications,
how do they fare against bias,
transparency, explainability,
extremely important when
you consider responsible ai,
as well as providing IP identification
for Amazon NOVA models.
In the second part it's
around having control.
Now this is a shared responsibility model.
We're working closely with
model providers around
how to make the models themselves safe,
but also we need to have
the right guardrails
around the models
and this is where Bedrock
Guardrails comes into play.
In order to be able to
help you govern those
for specific applications,
make sure that you control the ingress
as well as the egress of those LLM models.
Lastly, when it comes
to audit, data lineage,
observing what's happening
across the agent runs,
this is where I'll talk about
AgentCore observability,
but also our services such as CloudTrail
and CloudWatch have been there
in order to support that.
Now I talked about AgentCore,
I want to, you know, double
click on it slightly more.
There are three key areas with AgentCore.
We talked about agents having agency,
that's the first part.
It's around having tools and
memory to be able to realize
what is the session information,
what is the short term
as well as the long term so
that each time an agent is run,
it's able to learn from its experiences,
take those information
into account as memory
and enhance its output, but
also having access to tools.
And here I've highlighted two
of our native capabilities,
the code interpreter where
you can basically sort of
generate code but also securely
within a sandbox
environment, test that code
and run the code as well as browse tool
that would allow your agent to browse
and utilize a browser much
like a human would do.
In the second part it's
around deploying these
securely at scale.
So runtime and identity, which
I'll cover in the next slide,
are the key services in this area.
Lastly, but not least, it's important
to have view on the whole end-to-end
execution of these agents.
That's where AgentCore
observability comes into it.
So briefly, when it comes
to deploying these securely,
we have AgentCore runtime
which would allow you
to containerize your code
deployed into a cloud environment
within a customer VPC
securely and operate that.
So that's extremely important
to allow customers leverage
the IP of a partner per se
and run it within their own environment
and have guarantees around
what data can go outside
and what data can stay
within their own customer VPC environment.
AgentCore identity in particular
addresses one of the key
challenges that is access control.
Access control for the
user who's using the agent
because based on your
credentials you would have access
to certain resources and information
and every one of us would have
a different level of access
but also access control
for the agent itself
as it tries to access
resources across systems.
When it comes to tools and memory,
we have AgentCore Gateway
that would provide access
to a list of tools and
capabilities that are available
for the agent to be able
to take advantage of.
AgentCore memory would allow
you to, as we talked about,
improve your run based on taking account
of the shared context
between different agents
across sessions, be it
short term or long term.
And the last two I talked
about these from a browser
and code interpreter capabilities
and later on we'll see a demo
where we're actually
using a third party tool.
So these two are the native
tools provided by AWS.
Lastly, when it comes to
AgentCore observability,
we have integrations with
standard models such as OTel
and we are bringing that
data into CloudWatch
and CloudTrail so that users
can inspect agent runs,
perhaps diagnose any kind
of root cause of issues,
understand why certain patterns
and why certain traces were executed
and improve that over time.
With that said, I'm
gonna hand over to Andrei
to talk about Marketplace.
There you go.
- Thanks Salman.
So when we talk about
agents, they by default
consist of multiple components
including the LLMs in
many cases the tools,
the knowledge bases.
And one of the key challenges that I hear
from customers building or
experimenting with Agenda AI
is not how to build the agent,
but it is how to get access to
all the tools that they need.
Think of the new vendor
onboarding, security reviews,
legal reviews, payments set up,
all that can take from weeks
to months, slowing down
innovation and adoption.
And AWS Marketplace remove that friction.
Marketplace is an
enterprise-ready digital catalog
of software services and data.
And now also AI agents and tools.
For the developers who
are building agentic AI
Marketplace brings three key benefits.
The first one, the procurement
time drops from months
to days or minutes.
If Marketplace is already
configured in your organization,
Your developers can go to Marketplace,
find a tool they need and
subscribe in a single click
with the full transparency
about the pricing contractual terms.
So that's a big advantage
for the getting started time.
The second benefit is the unified billing
and the cost control transparency.
All the spend through AWS Marketplace
goes through your AWS
bill so your developers
don't need to put their own credit card
and do the expense reports for any tools
that they're experimenting with.
But in to that Marketplace integrates
with AWS cost tools such as budgets
and the cost explorers.
So you could set up
the certain spend goals
and have full transparency
on who's spending
and what they're spending
building agentic AI.
And finally that's the
actual developer experience.
It's a simplicity of deployment.
Marketplace products natively
integrates with AWS services.
So in a single click
you can deploy an agent
on AgentCore runtime.
I'll show you that in a later
part of my presentation.
So when a developer wants to
start with building an AI agent
or exploring a tool, evaluating a tool,
they can get started in
Marketplace with just a few clicks,
making it a one stop shop
for AI agents and tools.
We launched this category
just a few months ago in July
and it's been growing very fast.
Right now we have over 2300 agents, tools
and agentic applications
including professional services
from our partners.
They fall into different categories.
So let me break this down for you.
On the right hand of the slides
are the API based agents and tools,
those are the remote tools ISV hosted.
So for example, Tavily search
tool, you'll see it later
in Salman's section of the presentation.
From the developer standpoint,
they act as external targets.
So developers go to Marketplace,
they subscribe in a single click
and they can also in a single
click import those tools
into AgentCore Gateway as external targets
and then they can use or reuse those tools
in multiple agents for different kind
of applications they're building.
And then what's great is the automation
'cause AgentCore Gateway
automatically pulls down
all the metadata, the API, schema
and actions also we automate
the API key rotation
and give the full transparency
into what's happening with those tools.
So no manual wiring,
no schema translation,
gateway handles, all of that.
The second category on the
left portion of the slide
are container based agents and tools.
Those are containerized agents
that are designed specifically
to run on AgentCore runtime.
The key benefit, those
are run inside your VPC
on AgentCore runtime.
So you're getting all the benefits
of AgentCore service
including the VPC isolation,
Bedrock IAM based identity
and resource policies,
tool level permissions,
and of course observability.
So you're getting all the
benefits of the partner logic,
the partner defined
agents who have prebuilt,
who have done all the prompt engineering
but it runs within your VPC.
And the third category on the
bottom are agent applications
and also the professional services.
We hear from many of our customers
who are saying we need
some help to get started.
You can go on agent on AWS Marketplace
and find support from a broad
network of the partners.
So before we go deeper
into building the agents
and showing how that works, I
want to ground all the theory
that Salman and I have covered
in a real customer implementation.
Workday has been one of the early adopters
of AgentCore and other
AWS agentic services.
And please welcome on stage Mira
who will share their experience
of building a planning agent.
(audience clapping)
- Okay, thank you Andrei.
So I'm Mira Rajaram
and I head the AI core
services for Workday Planning.
So Workday, I think we
are perfectly positioned
to help our customers manage their money,
people and agents.
Now this is a marketing slide,
these are the list of agents
I'm allowed to show you
because these agents are
actually gonna be coming out
by end of this year in
the hands of customers.
There's a whole other
spreadsheet of agents
that we are working on
and that are gonna be following shortly.
So how are we getting
all these agents out?
Workday has an agent platform team
that's essentially making
some of these, you know,
common stack consistency to
how we are building agents.
So we leverage land graph,
we are using Lang Smith
for our evals and traces
and we have something
like a centralized gateway
to the LLM models, right?
So this is what we end up
leveraging across the board
and the planning agent is no different.
We are also leveraging that platform.
But let's dive into the planning agent.
So planning agent is one agent
that represents four personas
to give this complete
planning intelligence, right?
So the personas here, our analyst modeler,
the planner and the admin persona.
And based on the role like
we are essentially offering
the skills for those personas.
So if we dive a little
into the analyst role,
like one of the key things an
analyst does is explore data.
So let's dive into that.
So the data exploration
skill that we offer
essentially allows our end
users like these analysts
to leverage natural language
and conduct ad hoc analysis
on vast amounts of data.
And trust me when I say vast, it is vast.
So how did this this go about, you know,
for us, how are we successful at it?
Well I'll tell you, it
took us multiple tries.
Iteration one, let's get all this data,
let's send it to the LLM
and have the LLM do the
data analysis for us.
Okay.
We ran into a bunch of issues with that.
First we ran into token limits
because it was a lot of data.
Two, if we didn't run into token limits,
it was still an expensive solution
because we were sending
a large number of tokens,
and three, well LMS aren't
really very accurate with math.
So you know, this was not
a good solution for us.
Okay, let's see what else we can do.
And the team came up
with another solution.
So this was iteration two.
Token limits, we know how to solve it,
we will chunk the data
and send it to the LLM
and that's exactly what we did.
So it was a multi-step process.
We will chunk the data,
send it to the LLM,
get the output and send that output
and the next chunk of data to the LLM.
And of course this was not
a perfect solution again
because one is it introduced latency.
Two, we did solve for the token limits
but the solution is still expensive.
And three, we are still
not solved for accuracy.
Why?
Because at the heart of it,
LMS aren't great at math
but LMS are really good at writing code.
And so we figured that we
would rather get the LLM
to write code, Python code
that can do the data analysis
that we need and then the
LLM can leverage that output
and and be able to explain it right
and natural language to our end users.
So that's really what we went with.
Now why do we need a
sandbox code interpreter
and what exactly is this?
Well, show of hands for how
many people have raised kids.
Okay, okay.
We've got a few folks.
Well if you have got a high
energy toddler at home,
one way to deal with with that toddler
is to maybe create a playpen,
put them with all their toys,
they can create whatever mess
they want to in that playpen.
And the beauty is your fancy carpet
and walls are not disturbed.
So that's one way of doing it
and that's exactly what the
sandbox code interpreter is.
Think of your code like your toddler,
it can go wild, it can create a mess
and you wanna put it in a sandbox.
So that's exactly
what a sandbox code
interpreter allows you to do.
It is to ensure that your code can run
in a safe, secure environment.
Now we evaluated a lot
of different options.
One is should Workday build
our own sandbox code interpreter?
That's not the core of what Workday does,
so that's not gonna be
a good solution for us.
We then started looking at
different frameworks and tools.
Now if you've been in
this industry long enough,
you have seen a lot of demos
and these demos are amazing
because they tell you how
to build agents in an hour.
You can create POCs in an hour.
But taking that POC from POC stage
to production is a whole other matter
because you have to incorporate
all the enterprise controls,
you have to think about security,
you have to think about
like customer data,
which is so precious.
And so we said, hey, you know what?
We need a good solution that's
gonna help us address it.
And AgentCore essentially
provided that solution
like that was the answer
to what we were looking for
because one, it manages security for you.
So as far as your code is concerned,
that code is running in a very secured,
like a virtual computer, right?
The data that you have, your customer data
is uploaded into that environment
and as soon as you are done,
all of that data is wiped clean
and I'm now starting with
a, with a clean slate.
So that was super critical.
Second thing that the, you know,
AgentCore code interpreter
does, which is is kind
of a differentiator compared
to a lot of the other tools
is that it handles stateful
multi-step analysis.
So for that entire
session it's actually able
to do a multi-step
analysis process to ensure
that you get the most accurate results.
And then scalability, we are
actually able to send a ton
of data to the code interpreter,
at least with what we saw last.
We were able to upload anywhere
between a hundred MB file
for like inline processing
and of course we are compressing that file
and sending it over, but you
could also leverage S3 for it
where you can have up
to gigabytes of data.
So that's where we landed.
Now what did it take
us to get this solution
with AgentCore code
interpreter in production
took us one software developer,
two engineering managers
and three days to get this from POC
to something that can be production ready.
And that is is huge.
Like, you know, how many folks can say
that you can get something
from POC to production
in such a short span of time.
That's exactly what we got with
the agent code interpreter.
And by the way, we just went live
with our solution two weeks back.
So customers are actually
using this in production,
which is amazing.
So let's talk about some
of the results, right?
With the code interpreter solution,
what we ended up seeing is,
I mean yeah we are adding some
latency with code interpreter
somewhere in the ballpark
of 400 to 500 milliseconds.
If you look at the 90th percentile,
somewhere between one to two seconds.
But what we gained
is the token size reduced significantly.
So we are almost seeing
like when we have these large payloads,
we are seeing up to a 50%
reduction in the tokens
that we end up sending
and that's significantly
reducing the cost for us.
Two, the other benefit that we
are getting is the accuracy.
Like we ended up getting
much better results
with this solution than you know,
what we had done previously
so this was huge.
And three, scalability.
Like we now didn't have to worry about
are we gonna be hitting
token limits or any of that.
This solution is scalable
and at the end of the day,
like what is it our
customers are looking to do?
They wanna analyze large
reports, vast amounts of data
and this is exactly something
that's solving for it.
With that, I do want to thank
the close partnership we have had
with the planning agent team,
our own Workday agent platform team
and AWS, folks, like
this was a very strategic
partnership that helped us to innovate
at a really rapid pace.
With that, I will hand it off to Salman.
(audience clapping)
- Thank you Mira.
Okay,
we're gonna be building an agent.
Now disclaimer number one,
we're gonna be seeing some code
disclaimer number two, you can
definitely use AI to help you
with any form of coding.
I actually did use AI
to generate this code.
Third one, I gotta do this in 10 minutes.
So I'm gonna focus on the bare bones
of that capability that I talked about.
How do you bring that tool
and agency within the agent?
Where do you bring the
LLM that does a reasoning?
How do you bring in the query?
And then I'll give some pointers around
how you can start off but
also strengthen that in order
to move such a solution into production.
Now in this example I'm gonna be showing
how to build an agent using a
third party tool from Tavily.
So Tavily is an internet search
tool, provides a capability,
I'll talk to you about
how can you, you know,
take that tool, integrate it
within the code and and run it.
First is first what is the use case?
That's important, right?
And in this particular case,
I am gonna be demonstrating
a company research agent for sales team.
This happens to be a popular use case
that I'm seeing in production.
Reason being that many of the sales teams,
they focus on creating,
searching information from the internet,
creating these tailored briefing documents
ahead of their customer meetings.
So this is one use case that
I've seen emerge in production
and I thought, you know, like
create a simple, bare bone
capability to show how these are built.
Next one steps that we need to follow.
Step number one, we need
to architect the solution.
So we're gonna go over that.
Step number two, we
need to set up the tools
in the cloud environment.
I'll briefly touch upon that as well.
And then step number three,
we have to have the code
and then run it, right?
So step number one, solution components.
This is an overly simplified version
of solution components
involved in an agent.
You have the user that will be interacting
with an agent executor and
that executor takes on the role
of an orchestrator, right?
It sort of determines where's the LLM
that I need to sort of
take, take advantage of
in order to do that
reasoning and the planning.
What are the tools that have access
to me and what does that mean?
So in this case, in this
example, we have two tools.
One to represent information
that is coming from the
web and the internet.
And the second one is information
that is residing within
the enterprise environment.
In this particular
case, I just have a file
sitting on an Amazon S3 storage, right?
Just to show how the
two information can come
and be combined curated and
present a response to the user.
Now with each one of them we
need to have some decisions
around the technical capabilities.
So with the agent executor,
there's a number of
frameworks that are available.
Mira talked about land
graph, Lang chain is one
that is very close to that,
comes from from the from
Lang Chain provider.
So that's a framework we're gonna be using
in order to orchestrate
these capabilities.
From a reasoning LLM,
we have access to more than
200 models from Amazon Bedrock.
In this particular case
we're gonna see an example
from Anthropic Claude.
And then when it comes to the tooling,
the AgentCore gateway is gonna
be presenting us the option
of connecting to Tavily's tool
in order to se search internet.
And the local data search is
simply a tool function within
Python environment.
I think I've skipped that
part for the interest of time.
So we're gonna go over the example
and I'm gonna cover how
to now set up the tools
and the cloud environment
and then we'll go into
the code piece, right?
And I'll walk you
through what each section
of the code is doing so you can follow.
So the first thing around
the choice of the model,
you can go to Amazon Bedrock,
as I said, you've got access
to more than 200 models.
In this particular case the
use case seems simple enough.
So a model like Claude
3.5 high Q should be able
to, you know, provide a decent result.
Now within Bedrock
you have the Bedrock evaluation capability
where you can actually
test model side by side.
And those are some of the best practices
when you're moving and and executing
on a proof of concept
to be able to identify
what is the optimal model
for your particular use case.
But here for the sake of simplicity,
I'm going ahead with
clock 3.5 High Q model.
You can select the model
and then you can generate keys,
either short term or long term.
So in this instance we're
generating short term keys
and then we're storing these
within the secrets manager
as well as taking it and incorporated
into the code development that we have
that I'll show you later on.
Second part is around the tooling.
So as I talked about, you
know, we're using Tavily's tool
to search internet,
you'll be able to access
and get keys from Tavily.com.
And then again, same
practice with those API keys.
You can store them securely
within your Amazon environment
in the Secret Manager
and within AgentCore gateway
you can register this.
As it so happens within AgentCore gateway,
we have a number of native integrations.
So one of the options that
is the furthest to the right
talks about some of the
built-in integrations.
You'll be selecting that, Tavily is one
of the options tools available there
along with some other third party tools,
you'll be able to select that,
select your key and you'll be given
an AgentCore gateway URL and ARN.
They'll be using as part of your tool.
So that's your cloud
environment now set up.
Now let's move on to the code, right?
So in the simplest form, you
know, having that Lang Chain
that I talked about and
setting up the agent executor,
it's not that difficult.
So if you could just follow,
you know, the Python code here,
you'd be basically pulling
in some of the libraries
in this case Lang Chain.
And then there are a couple
of, you know, lines of code
where this agent executor comes
and sort of orchestrate all
the capabilities from the LLM,
the tools and the prompts.
You create that tool calling capability
and then you form an agent executor.
And once you have this object,
you can actually call invoke against that.
So then you can give a
user's query in order
to invoke this agent and
it would operationalize
and it would generate the response.
Three parts are key, the LLM,
the tools and the prompt.
These are the three
parameters that are provided.
So I'm gonna be talking about those three
parameters in the subsequent slide.
So this code highlights all three.
The first one is the LLM.
So in this case, again,
within Lang chain you'll
have native integration
with Amazon Bedrock.
You can simply use chat Bedrock
in order to select the model
and provide information
around, you know, the region
and the AWS credentials that you have.
So here you see the example
of Anthropic Claude 3.5
High Q being mentioned there
on the second one you
need to provide prompt.
So we talked about agents
following an objective.
Here I have an objective
and a read such as your
company research agent.
Your goal is to answer
questions about companies
using available data sources.
You have access to two tools, right?
To number one, search local documents,
search internal company
documents for information.
Number two, search the web, search the web
for current company information.
Fun fact, with AgentCore you
can't even have a separate
tool to say you can access,
you know, inquire on the list
of tools so you can get what
are the tools available.
Passes on to this reasoning LLM,
so that it can actually
in the subsequent stages
determine out of those
tools which ones to use.
But in this case, again,
I've kept it simple, right?
So I've provided those
tools that are relevant
to this agent directly within the prompt.
And the third one, you see that, you know,
we have tools as an array
that talks about these
two, search local documents
and search web,
I'm gonna skip the search local documents,
but again, I wanna show you
the code for search web.
So you can see how easy it is to bring all
of this capability into a
Python code and execute it.
First part, again, bringing
some of those configurations
that we have set up in
the cloud environment
in AWS environment from your
A WS region, your S3 buckets
or for the, you know, the local
search that I talked about.
And then the AgentCore URL and tool.
So those are the information
that we already had
from the AWS console.
You're gonna be able to
take advantage of it.
And then the search
web that was, you know,
mentioned in the array
is basically a function
and this function is decorated as a tool.
So then Python interpreter
environment will be able
to understand this is one of the tools
available for that agent.
And within that, you
know, we capture the name
of the tool from the AgentCore service,
we're gonna be able to
package this as a JSON RPC,
sign the query and then send
it over to AWS for invocation.
So in this case where you're seeing
the payload is packaged up
with some of the information
around the JSON RPC information,
also having arguments and
argument says query is query
the query parameter is
what the user provides.
And I'll show you the example,
you know, that we have
in the run, in the recorded run.
And then post that
you're gonna create this,
encapsulate this as a request, AWS request
and basically send this
request as a post operation.
So that's it.
This is whenever the agent de decides
to call the search web,
it would go through this,
it would have the response
and the response is being sent to the LLM
for further decision making
as to whether he needs
to further call tools
or whether he needs to
just curate the response
and provide an output to the user.
That's a decision that is left
with the LLM decide in this case.
So now I wanna show you
how this comes together when you run it.
And in this particular case
we need to have an example
of the query.
So the query here is
how has AWS's approach
to sustainability and
green computing evolved,
particularly focusing on their commitment
to run on a hundred
percent renewable energy.
So that's a query we're
gonna be pro providing it
to this agent and we're
gonna have the agent run
and I'm gonna show you the screenshots
of the run in this case.
So firstly, once you sort of run this,
it would actually try to figure out,
hey, do I have the
information or do I need to go
and use the tools that are available?
So the green is the JSON output
of what the LLM has determined.
It's determined that I
need to actually invoke
the search web tool that I have available
and it's also formed a query
that is different to the query that I had
in order to determine what is it
that I'm gonna be searching the web for?
So in this case it says
I wanna search the web
with the information AWS,
Amazon Web Services,
sustainability, renewable energy,
a hundred percent commitment progress.
So this is the determination of the LLM
saying I've seen the query and
I'm gonna be using this tool
and the tool is gonna be used
with this argument, right?
It's formed its own argument.
This tool is gonna be
invoked through, as I said,
AgentCore gateway and Tavily's tool
and it reverse with information.
Now you see a dense piece of text
is because it brings back
search results from the internet
relating to that argument,
relating to that query
and this particular case that you see
the information around
the Amazon Web Services
sustainability, renewable
energy commitments,
URLs so that you can have citations
and sort of, you know,
linkage the original material
as well as text.
Now I'm not gonna read over this text,
but what I'll highlight is ultimately
the LLM processes information
combined with the S3
information that it has
and it brings it and provides
this raw format in in JSON,
which can be, you know, processed further
in order to have a much
more human readable text.
But in this case, the
output that is provided
is based on the web search results.
I can provide a comprehensive overview
of AWS's approach to
sustainability and green computing
renewable energy commitment,
AWS has achieved its a hundred percent
renewable energy goal, seven years ahead
of scheduled target in 2021.
So I'm not gonna read the whole text,
but as you can see three steps.
One, we provided the sort
of query, step number two,
it's determined which tools to call
and which parameters to provide
for each one of those tools.
Step number three, curated the responses
and provided a response as an outcome.
So next steps from here,
this is the, you know,
the core building blocks
of building an agent,
but this in itself should
not be moving to production.
So number one is around
security and governance.
So with AgentCore Runtime,
and I didn't cover this
within today's session,
you'd be able to containerize this code
and push it into AgentCore
Runtime to operationalize.
So that's step number one.
Step number two is as I've
talked about these LLMs,
it's important to place
guardrails around the application.
So having those guardrails implemented
with Bedrock Guardrail is quite important.
Step number two is in terms of
performance and reliability.
In many of these applications
we see caching to be effective
because there's a lot of repeat queries
with the same kind of
company names or information.
So very much depends on
the application context
and having reliability say in
terms of failing over properly
in case a tool cannot be called
or the answer does not exist,
how do you recover from that?
Lastly, cost control.
You need to have mechanism
in place in order to realize
how much of LLMs are you calling,
what kind of token based pricing
is being generated here per request,
what the tool calls that you have.
All of those aspects would help you
to strengthen this in order to move it
into a production grade environment.
With that said, I'm
gonna hand over to Andrei
to talk about deploying a pre-built agent.
There we go.
- Thanks Salman.
So we just saw how to build
an agent from scratch,
Pick your LLM, pick your tools,
do the prompt engineering,
test that it's working,
which is great when you
want to have flexibility
and when you have the granular
control over the tool.
But many teams don't want
to start from scratch.
And sometimes the fastest path
is to start with a production
ready prebuilt agent
that you can get from
a third party vendor.
I'll be using a CRM AI sales agent
that is built by one of the vendors
available on AWS Marketplace
that can help you automate
the routine CRM tasks.
This is the fully packaged solution
with defined action schemas
with defined prompt engineering,
which has the recommended
LLM already baked in
and it is already packaged
and optimized to run on AgentCore runtime.
And that means you can
deploy it in minutes.
And I'm gonna show you
in just a few slides,
I'll show you the demo of
how that's gonna be done.
And this is the power of prebuilt.
You inherit all the vendors work
and they're kind like testing,
making sure that all things
and components work together,
but it can still run
securely in your environment
within your VPC.
Getting started experience
is extremely simple.
It is just three steps.
You first discover the agent
or the solution based
on your business needs.
We have the new agent
mode on AWS Marketplace
where you can describe
your business problem
or attach to your
internal requirements doc
or your plan for what
you're trying to build
and we'll give you the best
optimal solution for that.
The second is subscription
flow, which is a single click.
This particular tool is free
but it still requires
you to accept vendors'
terms and conditions.
And finally is the deployment process,
which is almost as
simple as a single click,
I'll talk about it a little bit more.
So Marketplace has
standardized the framework
for how to package, how to build
and package those containers.
And they come with vendor
authored instructions
and all the configuration
and require users to
provide only minimal inputs.
In this case users to deploy the agents
need to provide the environment variables
such as the CRM access credentials.
And what's important about Marketplace
is that it acts as the
supply and chain guardrail,
think of it this way,
all the agents that are
containerized applications
are stored in Marketplace
private ECR repo.
That means that vendors
cannot just swap the
image whenever they want.
All the images that they provide
goes through the rigorous
scanning process and they are
behind the entitlement enforced access.
So only users who are entitled
to use this product can
read them and the vendors
before pushing the new version have to go
through the full publishing
flow, full security reviews,
once it goes to the
AgentCore Runtime site,
that's where you get all the benefits
of running those agents within your VPC.
So you get IAM role configurations
where you start by either
creating a new IAM role
or selecting existing IAM
role if you have one already
where you define the minimal
required set of permissions
for this agent to upgrade properly,
which usually requires
access to Bedrock LLMs,
access to the tools you are using
or other internal resources
they require for the agent.
The secure runtime
environment within AgentCore
gives you the full control.
The agent would never leave
the boundaries of your VPC,
it's isolated from inbound
requests from the internet
unless you allow that
and you remain full control
over what the agent does
and how that operates.
So Marketplace in this case ensures
the trusted delivery of the agent
while agent call runtime
enforces secure governance
of the agents at the execution step.
So just to summarize, here's the flow.
If you want to get a third
party prebuilt agent,
again, it's very simple, you subscribe,
you find the Marketplace, subscribe,
you provide the environment variables,
in this case CRM credentials,
you deploy it on AgentCore
Runtime and you invoke the agent.
So let's see that in action.
I got a short prerecorded demo
just to put all this together.
We're starting on the Marketplace website
and we go to the new search experience
where you can describe your
problem in a natural language.
In this case, I'm looking for an AI agent
to automate my routine CRM actions.
And as you can see,
I'm typing very slowly.
If think for a few seconds,
you can also upload a document
with your requirements if you need more
and precise recommendations here.
And you'll see a few options,
with the generic recommended summary
and we just launched a new version
of that experience where
you can also create
an AI build comparison of different tools
so you can compare them
across different dimensions.
Once you identify the
tool that works for you,
you go to the product detail page
where you can read all the information
about how the tool works
and also see the deployment instructions
including the tool or in
this case agent schema
and the all the inputs
that are require from you
to make sure that this
agent operates properly.
Once you're ready, you
move to the purchase step
where you review pricing
in terms and conditions.
This tool is free but
you still need to hit
the subscribe button
to make sure you agree with
vendors' terms and conditions.
Once you're subscribed,
you can proceed to launching the software.
And this step, there are two options.
You can either proceed
with CLI if this is your preferred method
and we'll provide you a you pre-built,
pre-generated prompts for the CLI.
The first step would be
creating an IAM role.
Let's see.
Here it is.
So the first step will
be creating IAM roll.
So you can copy that
and execute this command
attaching permission policies.
And finally actually deploying the agents
with the container image
provided by the partner.
Or alternatively, you can
get the same work done
directly in the AgentCore console,
which we'll be using for this demo
and the AgentCore console.
Again, your inputs are fairly simple.
Provide a name for the agent.
It's pre-populated already,
but I prefer a different one.
Let's call it a Salesforce agent.
The ECR containers URI is
all already pre-populated
from the Marketplace.
The solution that you have just purchased,
you select or create a new IAM roll.
I have one already selected
and almost ready to hit the
hosting engine, but not yet.
I need to provide the
environment variables.
In this case I need to provide
four keys with respective values
and that's my CRM username.
This is my CRM password
and the token and the domain.
Again, this information
never leaves the boundaries
of your VPC.
This information is never
shared with the vendor.
And you can also store those credentials
in the Secrets Manager
and instead of providing variables here,
you can reference them
from the agent directly,
which is much better for the production
and when you need to do
the regular rotation.
So now let's test this
agent and see if that works.
I'm asking to provide me a
summary for the specific account.
And let's see.
We'll take a few seconds
to think and here we go.
So here's an example of an
agent that can help automate
the routine work of your sales teams.
And there are multiple ways
how we can plug in this agent
into your own individual workflows
with all the data, never
living the boundaries
of your VPC with you
having the full control,
but at the same time with
no building, no coding,
and no prompt engineering.
The one thing I also want to mention,
this particular agent built by Partner
is built using Strengths framework,
which already has Bedrock LMS baked in.
So in the previous example
you saw how we need
to pick an LLM, how we need
to configure the LLM access.
In this case you don't
need to do any of that.
It's kind of comes prebuilt.
And with that, that's the
end of our presentation.
We'll be wrapping up in a second.
Please join me on stage.
We are running a little short in time,
but as soon as we wrap up
we will be around here for Q and A.
- Thank you Andrei.
Despite his slow typing, I'm
still impressed, you know,
getting an agent into production
in five minutes as pretty impressive.
So what we saw today was AWS capabilities,
you know, providing prebuilt
agents, tools, models,
infrastructure and expertise.
Generally the best way to go about this
is to identify a use case
and start this flywheel cycle, right?
What is the use case?
What is the business pain
point or opportunity?
Identify how, whether
we should be building
or buying or partnering.
And then, you know, create
this flywheel effect
that you can improve over time.
There are some resources
that are available
and this recording is
gonna be available as well.
So we've got information
around some of the sample code
with AgentCore,
but also some training
material to improve your skills
with our agentic AI offerings.
And lastly, I wanna close off with some
of the relevant sessions
that are also covering
similar topics at reinvent.
Thank you so much for being with us.
Thank you.
- [Andrei] Thank you.